Speaker 1: so I already told you about the
announcement of Trump's Truth social social
media site, which doesn't even allow
you to criticize it on its own site.
Not very free speech. This is just a funny
coda on this story. Trump's Truth Social
was hacked within hours of the announcement.
Newsweek reporting former President Trump's
new social media platform reportedly
hacked within hours of its announcement,
people were able to the truth. Social app will
begin a beta test for invited guests in November,
but people were able to sign up to create
accounts using a publicly available link,
Drew Harwell, a tech reporter for The Washington
Post, said on Twitter. I literally just registered
Mike Pence. The site hasn't even launched and
it's already vulnerable. In a subsequent tweet,
he revealed that account had been suspended. And
if we look at actually, I don't have access to
it. In the immediate but already problematic
in another tweet, Harwell said it appeared the
Donald J. Trump account on Truth Social had been
hacked. A screenshot Harwell shared showed the
post was of a defecating animal. However, it's not
clear if the account belongs to Trump, right? The
Trump may have posted a picture of a defecating
animal. It's not clear, but it appears as though
it's probably been hacked. It's it's been
censored here so that it's family friendly,
so that's pretty exciting. Meanwhile, Mikhail
Falen, a reporter for the Daily Dot, tweeted
he was able to create an account using the handle.
Donald Trump before the public domain for the site
was taken down, was just able to set up an account
using the handle. Donald Trump on Truth Social
Although the site isn't open, a URL was
discovered allowing users to sign up anyway.
It's now been taken off line complete and total
chaos, absolutely complete and total chaos. So
already apparently hacked and vulnerable, which
is pretty similar to what we saw happening with
the Mike Pillow platform as well. So a lot of
things going wrong quickly in the early hours. My
prediction trumps truth. Social platform is going
to lead to a lot, a lot of comedy. We'll have more
on this on The David Pakman Show Instagram,
which you can find at David Pakman show.